i'm amazed that you're here promoting
two projects at a time when it's
impossible for people to make anything
so i tipped my cap to you if i had a cap
thank you i i i'm just so insanely
grateful to have something to talk about
besides politics the weather and
the the dumpster fire of a planet right
now yeah
i i'm and you know i'm thrilled i just
saw this picture today because you
posted it but that you are
still able to be you guys are making uh
more of uh marvelous mrs maisel and you
posted this picture
that i want to show of you now it looks
like you're in an
oxygen tent um this is you
uh working i guess in some kind of a
bubble this allows you to stay
safe is that true yeah that is a
brilliant invention
by our covid safety team it's a it's a
hepa filtered
umbrella we are taking pitches for the
names so
please submit any and anything and
everything to us
yeah this is called a celebrity bubble
that's what it is
[Laughter]
i just think they should still have
award shows but everyone should have to
walk down the carpet
in one of these like wouldn't that be
kind of
interesting and fun yes
thanks for thanks for playing along with
that uh
no i'm really looking forward to a time
when where i feel like it's
i think we all feel this way like it's
close the vaccine is
out there we don't know when we're gonna
get it
but at least we think maybe sometime in
the next couple of months
so yes there's light at the end of the
tunnel i promise you
i mean i said i did i said dumpster fire
of a planet but that was that was
a little bit further in the past today
like you said i think
especially yesterday i feel i feel
hopeful
yeah there is definitely light yeah no
it no it's nice it's nice we're in
sitting in the back seat of a car and
now it feels like at least someone with
a driver's license is behind the wheel
so yes you know that's a little bit the
feeling that i have